[Musique]
sur les routes gâtinaise il faut suivre
les panneaux il vous emmène droit vers
cette ancienne usine en 2017 après six
mois de travaux l'auto sport museum
ouvre ses portes et c'est cet homme
didier soucheyre qui en est à l'origine
quand on est collectionneur il ya
toujours un moment où on manque de place
donc j'ai commencé à collectionner les
voitures chez moi j'ai commencé à
remplir mon garage comme tout
collectionneur qui se respecte quand
j'ai atteint les limites du garage me
suis dis bah faut arrêter de
collectionner ou alors il faut trouver
un autre endroit et puis en fait on
promenons dans la région mena lors des
rassemblements de voitures j'ai
rencontré d'autres collectionneurs qui
avaient exactement la même problématique
bien sûr et d'où des discussions se
disent on bat si un jour on trouve un
hangar où un local pourquoi nous pour y
exposer quelques voitures ça nous fera
de la place dans les garages et puis ça
permettra peut-être même dans
collectionner d'autres ce temple de 2000
m² dédiés à la voiture sportive des
années 50 à 90 accueille près de 80
véhicules appartenant aux adhérents de
l'association
il y à des constructeurs connus les
américains chevrolet et corvette
l'anglais jaguar le japonais honda ou
les français peugeot et renault et on
retrouve aussi des modèles beaucoup
moins répandue
c'est le modèle le plus rare qu'on a
dans le musée 19 exemplaires produits
seulement dans le monde et en fait c'est
un constructeur anglais marcos qui
fabrique les voitures à l'unité qui a
fait ces véhicules équipés d'un 2 litres
turbocompressé voiture de 1995 modèle
qui est unique en france autre bijou
c'est aux mails des années 90 fabriqué
par le groupe de presse français du même
nom
c'est des véhicules qui ont été produits
à quelques dizaines d'exemplaires qui
ont été vendus à l'origine via le
magazine échappement qui est un magazine
très connu des amateurs de sport auto
est en fait qui ont donné lieu à
plusieurs versions des versions coupé on
va dire grand tourisme c'est plutôt une
voiture de course et des versions
carrément destinée pour le circuit
ici pas de texte à rallonge pour
découvrir les secrets qui se cachent
sous les carrosseries tout se passe sur
le téléphone grâce aux qr code
s'est aussi essayé de se mettre à jour
au niveau au niveau numérique d'attirer
aussi peut-être un public un peu plus
jeune qui a l'habitude d'utiliser le
téléphone et pour qui tout est assez
intuitif et puis pour éviter d'avoir
trop de lecture aussi dans le musée au
quotidien le musée géré par une
association et sa centaine d'adhérents
tu vois sur franchement j'étais
il ya par exemple jean et son alfa romeo
de 1989 il a une vingtaine de voitures
et de motos dans son garage
mon père était dans la mécanique et je
suis vivant comme un verrou vinpearl
votre hymne est joué j'ai beau boulot
dur des
dernières longtemps
cet ancien mécano a le matériel chez lui
mais tout le monde n'a pas cette chance
alors en échange de leurs cotisations
vas-y du droit ils peuvent venir à
l'atelier du musée du stop
jean-alain est là pour donner un coup de
main changer des pièces qui semblent
défectueuse les conseiller et les aider
à démonter certaines pièces qu'il veut
changer sur leur voiture parce qu'ils
sont rendus compte que effectivement
s'était abîmé notamment sur le système
de freinage les pneus les choses sur
cette simca de 1955 on vérifie le filtre
à air l'entretien de ces voitures
anciennes et régulier ce qui permet à
80% des modèles exposés de rouler avec
celle là j'ai fait le rallye national
c'est qu'on a fait 2000 km il ya quatre
ans on évite de sortir quand tu as trop
mauvais mais dès qu'il fait beau on
n'hésite pas à prendre les voitures
l'amusé à but non lucratif est devenu
une attraction du gâtinais chaque année
près de 3000 visiteurs viennent admirer
les bolides de l'autosport musée